[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich bin ja gerade voll im putz
fieber machen einen frühjahrsputz
ich habe schon fast das ganze haus
geputzt außer die küche und die bäder
der küche und bäder die sind für mich so
ein eigenständiges objekt es dauert
extrem viel zeit die küche auszuräumen
den frühjahrsputz bedeutet für mich an
schränke von innen aus vision von außen
aus zwischen auslisten aufräumen schön
sortiert wieder zurück räumen daher
könnt ihr euch da wirklich auch einen
ganzen tag dafür zeit nehmen unsere
küche ist halt nicht so vollgestellt wie
vielleicht manch andere ich weiß nicht
aber wir haben halt nicht so und eine
mikrowelle wo alles drauf steht oder
gewürze die draufstehen und offen
herumstehen deswegen ich zeige euch
jetzt mal
wir fangen von innen nach außen an bei
der küche ist nämlich ganz wichtig erst
mal die schränke nicht komplett
ausräumen sondern schrank für schrank
ausräumen auswischen das mache ich hier
im alltag reiniger schön sortieren und
dann wieder zurück und das machen wir
jetzt auch wie so eine art keine rom
tour mit der neuen küche her denn die
hatte ich noch nicht gezeigt erstmal
hier weg räumen und dann geht's los
wenn ihr eingebrannt sind backöfen habt
wer das jetzt die perfekte zeit um sie
jetzt einzureiben damit sie einwirken
können
ich habe dafür einfach im backofen und
grill reiniger der würde zu hier
reinkommen der hier oben hat eco klien
das heißt die seitenteile muss ich
sowieso nie sauber machen er reinigt
sich dann von alleine
hier muss ich nur den boden sauber
machen aber hier sieht jetzt alles
sauber aus das einzige was ich gleich
machen werde ist hier noch die
backbleche ein bisschen mit backofen
reiniger einzureiben und die lege ich
dann hier rein und dann können sie
nämlich ein wirken wie sich eben die
übrige küche geputzt habe das wollen wir
jetzt doch kurz zusammen
[Musik]
bei backofen reinigern müsst ihr euch
wirklich immer schützen mit handschuhen
und am besten im der bürste und passt
auch immer auf eurer übrigen gegenstände
auf also nicht an edelstahl kommen nicht
ins edelstahl waschbecken oder auf stein
oberflächen denn sonst macht ihr euch
die oberflächen kaputt viele würde jetzt
wahrscheinlich sagen hier so schmutzig
ist der backofen doch gar nicht aber
mein tipp an euch lasst eure backofen
überreste nicht ein brennen denn
ansonsten wird es immer schlimmer und
ihr müsst immer mehr putzen und
schrubben ich mache das wirklich so dass
der backofen immer sauber ist einmal die
woche machen wir dann backofen reiniger
rein und dann hab da auch wirklich nur
ganz wenig arbeit damit ich werde das
jetzt also ich mache das hier kurz
darauf dass es dann ein wirkung auch
schön die waldfläche nur wirklich drauf
streichen und dann muss man auch nicht
stoppen
ich hab ich hier einen recht starken
backofen reiniger da könnt ihr euch
wieder diesen kreis vorstellen diesen
reinigungs kreis ich habe jetzt hier die
den faktor chemie
dann gibt es den faktor zeit also das
einwirken lassen und den faktor mechanik
also das schrubben
wenn ihr jetzt einen sehr starken
reiniger habt fallen natürlich die
anderen etwas weg oder werden hat kürzer
das heißt ich schreib das jetzt hier nur
ein muss nicht trocken aber ich muss
natürlich auf zeit gehen das heißt ich
lasse es ein segen
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel den
faktor chemie einfach runter schrauben
und sagen ich will gar nicht so starken
reiniger zu hause haben dann nehmen wir
zum beispiel rasierschaum könnte hier
den ganzen backofen mit rasierschaum
einweichen auch die backbleche und das
backofenfest und dann gebt ihr da
entweder eine folie drauf damit es nicht
so vertrocknet und lasst es dann aber
wirklich für 8 und zwar 24 bis 48
stunden einwirken
das heißt da verringert sich der faktor
chemie aber der faktor zeit kommt eben
dazu und so könnt ihr eben selbst
ablegen möchte ich jetzt nicht im
backofen haben und den reinigen oder
will ich etwas schrubben also
abschrubben ganz normal mit einer bürste
geht natürlich auch aber es geht dann
halt auf die kraft ist das wirklich der
reinschalten hier sieht man schon die
sind ganz stark alleiniger es gibt eine
allein schon durch sein reiben weg aber
ich werde jetzt gleich einbrechen lassen
und dann jetzt mit däninnen sprengen
weiter
[Musik]
anfangen werde ich jetzt von oben nach
unten weil natürlich der schmutz von
oben nach unten fällt
ich mache jetzt hier hinten erstmal
unsere schränke das sind offene aber
auch geschlossene schränke irrsee zwei
den stories in den videos immer offen
aber wir haben sie abends immer zu wenn
sie abends immer zu wenn wir schlafen
gehen oder auch tagsüber wenn wir sie
nicht nutzen
das heißt es in zwar schränke die offen
sind bei benutzung und deswegen nicht so
sehr ein sterben aber wenn man sie eben
nicht brauchen dann sind sie zu trotzdem
muss man die natürlich jetzt ausnutzen
das mache ich erstmal innen drin und
danach kommen dann eben die fronten
das heißt ich würde sie aber so vorgehen
nicht alles ausräumen und eure ganze
küche vorstellen sondern wirklich
schrank für schrank regal für regal
ansonsten entsteht nämlich ein reines
chaos und wir dann wirklich mal eine
pause braucht oder eben ist kurzfristig
weg dann steht die küche trotzdem wieder
ordentlich aus ich habe zehn
allzweckreiniger den schüttelt die dann
immer vor der benutzung hier ein
handtuch kann ich nicht schön abstützen
und tut mir nicht weh träume alles aus
die sachen werden bei uns auch
regelmäßig einfach immer wieder
ausgeräumt gewaschen und eben auch
benutzt und es ist auch der richtige
moment um dinge auszumisten um sie
wegzubringen zu verschenken oder sachen
wegzuschmeißen
denn alles was er ein jahr lang nicht
braucht also eigentlich gibt es in der
regel wenn ihr etwas drei monate lang
nicht braucht brauchst du nicht auf
augenhöhe zu sein wenn ihr etwas ein
halbes jahr nicht braucht muss man sich
schon überlegen brauche ich es überhaupt
und wenn ihr etwas ein jahr lang nicht
braucht weil es im keller liegt oder
egal wo dann verschenkt oder schmeißt
einfach weg ansonsten belastet euch das
neue haus steht voll und ihr räumt im
prinzip nur euren dingen hinterher
der rat hat mal gesagt alles was du
besitzt besitzt auch dich und da muss
immer daran denken
und deswegen steht bei uns halt generell
nicht so viel herum sondern nur
nützliche dinge
[Musik]
jetzt natürlich auch unter der decke
alles mit erwischen nicht mischen
sondern vision und ich habe sie ihren
entscheidenden vorteil denn hier waren
eigentlich hoch schränke geplant sowie
in meiner alten küche mit der ablage
obendrauf
und dann habe ich es sagt vista was ich
habe keine lust mehr auf die ablage in
der küche denn er kennt wahrscheinlich
von zu hause die ablage oben
sie sind meine staub und fett ablage
also haben wir hier alles zugebaut mit
den hölzern einfach mit so einer
trockenbauweise und deswegen habe ich
jetzt keine oberfläche mehr
hier muss ich später einfach nur die
front ab wir schon fertig das echten
richtig guter vorteil davon
[Musik]
hier habe ich die kaffeemaschine weg die
es später dran
[Musik]
jeder hier bis hier auch einfach dinge
ausgemistet das haben wir mal geschenkt
gekriegt benutzen es aber nie ich tu's
einfach weg
[Musik]
regel eins ist schon mal fertig hier
unten mache ich erst später wenn ich die
arbeitsfläche dann mache was 14 uhr
machen wir das in dinge weg räumen die
noch nicht hingehören ellas muffins die
sie unbedingt haben wollte sie will dass
wir die nach backen
der hat sich gesehen also hab ich ihr
versprochen nach dem putzen habe ich
gesagt das habe ich jetzt hier noch weg
mache jetzt hier mit den regalen oben
weiter und dann zeige ich euch gleich es
weitergeht
[Musik]
hier oben bin ich jetzt erst mal fertig
jetzt werde ich hier seitlich mit meinen
küchenschränken anfang ich muss aber
dazu sagen hier an der seite habe ich
extrem viel stauraum
aber ich habe noch kein staub gut also
die meisten schränke sind noch leer
die ganz oben die brauche ich gar nicht
zu machen aber dann geht es gleich mit
dem kühlschrank weiter und mit den
unterschränken da ist ziemlich
unordentlich
das tuch ist dann natürlich
zwischendurch immer mal wieder sauber
machen und auch mal das tuch wechseln
[Musik]
also alles was ich hier weniger oft
brauche kommt weiter nach oben
und was ich öfter brauche kommt hier
weiter nach oben
[Musik]
jetzt ist der kühlschrank dran
den werde ich jetzt kurz ausschalten
weil ich ihnen jetzt natürlich länger
offen halten muss
ich räume jetzt einmal kurz aus und ich
habe übrigens auch ein kühlschrank video
schon gemacht also wenn ihr wissen wollt
wie mein kühlschrank richtig einräumt
anschaut da vorbei ich habe jetzt hier
alles aus und habe jetzt hier auch schon
mal wasser gerichtet das ist ganz
frisches wasser ein frisches tuch und
ich gebe es hier ein bisschen
essigessenz rein
ihr könnt aber auch wieder sinn alles
reiniger benutzen aber sind alles
reiniger nämlich eigentlich nicht den
kühlschrank wöchentlich auswischen
und wenn ich ihnen noch mal so grund so
eine grundreinigung mache was ich es
gern mit frischem wasser aus wolfsbuch
einfach immer wieder auch sauber machen
kann
irgendwie schon
[Musik]
bei starken verschmutzungen würde ich
euch jetzt raten all diese glasteile
auch noch raus zu nehmen hier draußen an
der tür nämlich alle raus aber die hier
die sind echt super sauber ist also
sagte ich nun alles einige reihen mit
meinem essig tuch und dann wird alles
schön gereinigt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der kühlschrank ist fertig die türen
sind jetzt auch von innen schon geputzt
und jetzt ist das gefrierfach noch dran
ja da sind die kinder öfter mal dran
man sieht
[Musik]
guckt mal immer schön bananen im vorwort
und irgendwo im vorrat die bananen die
friere ich meist ein wenn ich merke okay
sind schon richtig reif aber ich brauche
sie gerade nicht
dann fließt es einfach so ein die werden
zwar von außen braun aber innen sind sie
noch schön weiß und dann könnt ihr
nämlich einfach schälen und für
smoothies benutzen habt schön schon mal
die kälte mit drin
und irgendwie habe ich sowieso immer
daran so gefroren und frisch ist hier
alles durcheinander und dann nutze ich
jetzt auch die gelegenheit um alles
wieder schön aufgeräumt noch schmecken -
schnecken diesmal noch auf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich sollte jetzt meine vorräte hier mal
um
denn ich habe hier in der küche immer
viele tiefe vorne früchte und nicht so
viel fleisch eigentlich also mache ich
jetzt die tk früchte hier unten rein
bananen dass ich da oben drin perfekt
und das fleisch kommt dann ins und
kräuter und gemüse kommen auch hinten ja
eine gefrorene yogurette ihr dürft eure
pause nicht vergessen beim frühjahrsputz
ist ja die operette gerochen
ich wollte ich gerade rufen
ich habe eine korrekte gefunden wo sie
war
die lag da so wenn ich jetzt sagen wo
ich gefunden habe
dann platzte es immer wieder
[Musik]
ich habe ich übrigens so ein zweiter
kühlschrank mit gefrierfach war der
kleine vorne nicht ausreicht und die
habe ich dann auch die weiteren vorräte
das habe ich jetzt auch gleichzeitig mit
ausgeräumt der größte teil ist es schon
mal geschafft jetzt sind die unteren
schränke dran
ich fange jetzt hier erst mal hier bei
der rückwand an danach nehme ich mir
hier die seite vorbei den backöfen und
am ende dann die insel fahren jetzt
einfach wieder von oben nach unten an
von links nach rechts
die leisten hier dürfte auch nicht
vergessen das sind so die stockflecken
die mache ich aber eigentlich auch jeden
tag sauber weil da immer was rein
krümelt und jetzt einfach alles raus
räumen muss zwischen und wieder
einräumen
[Musik]
ich habe hier übrigens zur kleine
einteiler drin sind magnetisch also mit
seiner magnetischen rückwand war ich
praktisch vor allem kann man hier die
zwischen fächer richtig gut vorstellen
und so bleibt alles schön ordentlich und
fertig kann jetzt wieder alles einräumen
ich habe mich so die kaffee sachen aber
da kann ich ja mal ein organisations
video machen
[Musik]
beim ausräumen achte ich schon drauf
dass ich die sachen sortiere denn
oftmals kommt hier die ordnung auch ein
bisschen durcheinander
und wenn jetzt gleich sortiert habe das
später einfach ein bisschen einfacher
die snacks kochen
[Musik]
ich bin halt immer so hin und
hergerissen sollte ich es nach größe
oder nach farben weiß ich nicht was
würdet ihr machen würdet ihr es nach
größe sortieren als zu groß zu groß
und dann so die größe und dann die busse
oder halt eher farben weiß blau gelb
stimmt mal ab ich sortiere es jetzt
irgendwie ein und dann fertig ist wieder
oben wenn ihr abgestimmt hat sowieso
klein sondern schnickschnack
sara wir machen schnickschnack schnappte
farbe oder größe
ich bin größer erich zeige grüßen
drei durchgänge war einfach nur schlecht
aber nur schere stein papier schnick
schnack schnuck herstellung
[Musik]
nicht du musst nicht kaputt machen auch
so nicht nur so entscheiden
[Musik]
nach größe bis jetzt blicken hier so ihr
lieben farben
dieser hat euch getrennt
so halt halt da gibt es jetzt noch sache
und macht das ganze schon mal raus
bringen kann sich hier fertig die
mülheimer sind übrigens auch immer
sauberer denn nicht nur sie nach jedem
müll rausbringen also jeden tag einmal
kurz durch wischen und da gibt es ein
richtig coolen tricks und zwar nimmt
jetzt erstmal alles reiniger erstmal
schön sauber machen
zwischen unternehmen jetzt einfach
küchenrolle oder nehmen das tuch was ihr
die ganze zeit schon benutzt habt und
schutz dann aber in die wäsche so beim
nach mülleimer finde ich sollte man das
buch nicht nochmal weiter benutzen und
dann könnt ihr müll einmal geruch
vorbeugen indem ihr hier unten jetzt
etwas küchenrolle reinlegt und nehmt
dann etwas orangen oder teebaumöl ich
mag ganz gerne orange und tropft es hier
einfach auf tour
[Musik]
kirchen party geht weiter
die unterschränke sind jetzt auch fertig
die sally ist glücklich denn die innen
schränke sind jetzt alle ausgewaschen
jetzt geht es an die oberfläche hier bin
ich jetzt erstmal an der kochstelle ich
habe übrigens den topf immer hier stehen
zum einen ist dekorativ und passen in
die küche petrol und senf und zum
anderen benutze ich ihn einfach echt oft
und er passt einfach nicht hier in den
unterschrank weil ich da andere töpfe
drin haben und ich finden halt schön so
die teekanne kann ich jetzt auch mal zum
auswaschen nach hinten stellen bei der
kochstelle mache ich jetzt so was muss
ich auch mehrmals machen die woche also
das sind einfach dinge frühjahrsputz
bedeutet nicht dass ich nur dinge machen
die ich im frühjahr machen sondern
einfach dinge die ich noch zusätzlich
machen hier erstmal vom dampf ab zog die
filter auswechseln bzw in die
spülmaschine
ich habe jetzt auch die spülmaschine
noch nicht so toll das heißt hier kann
ich jetzt alles ein geben und auch
gleich anschalten und wenn ich dann
nämlich fertig bin ist die spülmaschine
auch fertig und die kann ich dann auch
noch zum schluss reinigen
die edelstahlteile die abdeckung waschi
per hand und die finther kommen in die
spülmaschine gemeinsam mit diesen zwei
ebenen teilen vom waschbecken und ich
hole auch gleich noch alles aus der
kaffeemaschine rauf dann kann ich
nämlich die spülmaschine anschmeißen auf
einem kurzprogramm muss jetzt nicht so
mega heiß werden dass sie nämlich nicht
voll und kann dann die küche weiter
kosten und später mich noch um die
spülmaschine kümmern
[Musik]
nur aus bürsten und das per hand
reinigen
und da müsste einfach auf ihren geräten
schauen das darf zum beispiel nicht in
die spülmaschine weil es dann
wahrscheinlich auch ganz blind wird und
sich verzählt reinige ich jetzt kurz
alles per hand und der rest gemacht
und wie passt kannst dich so lange
bekannt
[Musik]
wenn ihr übrigens kalkigen geräte habt
oder wasserkocher
wir haben hier die teekanne dann gebt
ihr jetzt einfach wasser rein und
zitronensäure
wir haben zwar eine bwt anlage also eine
entkalkung anlage aber trotzdem haben
wir natürlich mit der zeit karl drin und
ich gebe jetzt hier einfach wasser rein
und dann wirklich nur ganz wenig
zitronensäure das kann ich es aufkochen
lassen und das heiße wasser benutze ich
dann aber auch gleich noch ums
waschbecken sauber zu machen
das mache ich auch regelmäßig aber ich
empfehle euch wirklich eine
enthärtungsanlage denn ihr schon teure
geräte ihr schon teurere er schon teure
spülmaschine beim duschen braucht ihr
weniger duschgel weniger shampoo also es
lohnt sich wirklich auf den ersten blick
denkt man sich vielleicht ob sie brauche
ich das aber glaubt mir es lohnt sich ja
mal schon wirklich alles uns bleibt
ziemlich karg frei und zwar schmecken
besser und weicher und dieses
zitronensäure wasser ist jetzt wirklich
der beste kalt löser
das nimmt er jetzt geht zum waschbecken
und können einfach schön über das
waschbecken ließen
der kalk löst sich fast von alleine und
damit könnt ihr auch den herd noch ein
bisschen platz überwog alkis badezimmer
können das mitnehmen einfach drüber
gießen
mit meinem allzweckreiniger reinige ich
jetzt hier noch im filter drinnen
denn da ist ja auch bett lösen und jetzt
komme ich zum ceranfeld da habe ich
einen ganz normalen ceranfeld reiniger
den ich jeden tag benutzt da ist nämlich
für edelstahl und 14 kinder und da nehme
ich die weiche seite des schwammes keine
zier schon drüber putzen
und danach schön aus wissen und trocken
[Musik]
sieht aus wie neu was gibt's jetzt noch
zu tun
jetzt werde ich die fronten putzen darf
er nämlich einfach jetzt ein frisches
tuch meinen allzweckreiniger mache hier
die schränke erst mal von außen sauber
alle fronten von vorne und dann bleiben
im prinzip nur noch die backöfen und das
waschbecken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt sind auch alle fronten und
oberflächen sauber
ich fühle mich wirklich supergut jetzt
kommen noch die waschbecken dran ich
mache das erste dann die backöfen gleich
noch fertig und zwei waschbecken ich
mache mal eins dann eben ganz zum
schluss hier nehmt ihr jetzt je nach
verschmutzungsgrad auch ein waschbecken
reiniger ich hab da einfach so ein
edelstein reiniger den ich auch immer
benutzt deswegen habe ich auch hier kaum
verfärbungen
wenn ihr aber wirklich auch noch starke
verfärbungen habt ihr könnt auch immer
gut kohler nehmen die hatte ich beim
ausräumen getränke kühlschrank gefunden
und damit könnt ihr die toilette gut
sauber machen hier das waschbecken
saubermachen und ich werde aber gleich
noch alles einfach damit wirklich rein
und sauber wird mit einem dampfreiniger
durchpusten so werden auch die rohre
unten sauber hier diese kleinen ecken wo
ich nicht so gut dran kommen werden
sauber und ich kann eben auch alles
schön bakterien frei bekommen mit dem
heißen wasser mit dem heißen dampf
[Musik]
wenn ihr ganz starke verkalkungen habt
könnte auch hier wieder zitronensäure
und warmes wasser nehmen oder auch ein
bisschen richtig bei es ich muss man
sehr vorsichtig sein weil er sich
kunststoff an greift also gerade
armaturen baidu schrauben zum beispiel
lieber er zitronensäure nehmen da machte
nämlich nichts kaputt also auch keine
dichtung breite es jetzt kurz ausspülen
jetzt wird alles schön mit dampf sauber
gemacht und bei dampf hat man auch den
vorteil dass man nicht so einen großen
wasser verbraucht wie wir mal jetzt
ständig mit fließendem wasser arbeitet
und gar der abfluss oder diese kleinen
stellen hier im waschbecken sind ebenso
kleine details die man gerne im alltag
oft vergisst die man auch nicht sieht
aber man riecht sie wenn man es eben
nicht sauber macht und hier könnt ihr
entweder wie gesagt einem dampfreiniger
rhein mit heißem wasser oder ihr könnt
auch mal natron reingeben natron reinigt
nämlich auch und neutralisiert vor allem
gerüchte
[Musik]
gegen luke eingewirkt
[Applaus]
guckt wie neu und wasser sparen könnt
ihr hier übrigens wenn ihr das blech
nicht per hand dann reinigt sondern
einfach mit den geschirrspüler gibt bei
mir ist jetzt aber schon an und da habe
ich kurzerhand gereinigt aber dann könnt
ihr euch das in arbeits bürger sparen
jetzt muss ich nur noch kurz den
backofen auswischen und trocknen
[Musik]
das mache ich jetzt zwei dreimal damit
wirklich der ganze reiniger entfernt
wird
[Musik]
wie neu
ich habe jetzt nur noch drei stationen
nummer eins die fenster nummer zwei das
waschbecken nummer drei der boden die
fensterputzer jetzt erstmal innen alle
rahmen und dann von außen nur bei außen-
und las ich vielleicht monat machen
ja das haben wir noch mithelfen das
zeigen wir bis zum schluss aufgespart
da sieht man gleich ergebnisse
[Musik]
während murat jetzt draußen noch unten
das fenster macht kann ich schon das
waschbecken machen
[Musik]
du kannst auch dann damit die das brett
machen weiß aber ganz zum schluss und
natürlich das tuch in die wir schon hier
noch 1 hallo um die ecke ja so einmal
muss gar nicht drücken
cool und das fenster war schon sehr sehr
dreckig cross-border aber der sound ist
auch heuer um bessere bilder
fenster sauger murat
[Musik]
ich habe es geschafft die küche ist
sauber morast darf jetzt noch saugen und
wischen wobei ich gestern schon gesaugt
und gewischt hat beim kompletten
frühjahrsputz aber jetzt habe ich hier
natürlich auch nochmal direkt verursacht
das darf es machen und morgen gehe ich
dann in die badezimmer badezimmer noch
sauber nimmt sich am besten immer jeden
tag ein bisschen was vor denn wenn man
es richtig gründlich machen will jeden
schrank rhein haben will und dann gleich
noch auflistet und aussortiert und
wieder einsortiert dann ist es doch für
einen tag ziemlich viel also teils euch
gut aufhört gute musik dabei trinkt und
es zwischendurch und hat viel spaß beim
putzen bis zum nächsten mal
jetzt bin ich glücklich denn die küche
ist weder sein
[Musik]